hey that's still how you hug people
why don't you hug me like you haven't
seen me for three years
[Music]
who are you staying in a hotel I get a
good rate because I travel so much and I
like hotel rooms I told you it was going
to be a Fast Trip
you look good when did you dye your hair
a year ago okay I didn't I didn't really
know that well you would have if we'd
ever Skyped her face timed or whatever
how your sister's doing Rachel living on
her own now after her mom died Maggie
went to college and then she just
suddenly quit doesn't Rachel seem a
little off to you she did say she's
depressed okay well I've never seen her
depressed maybe it's more to do with
Nathan we can track him down you don't
think I would win in a fight against
Nathan
do you know about the party I'm having
at my house tomorrow night you should
definitely come Eric might be leaving
tomorrow
it's hard to predict I'm like waiting
for some phone calls where were you last
night
we play again tomorrow aren't you
leaving tomorrow I'll change my flight
thank you for sacrificing so much of
yourself
why does Rachel hate me the other way
around you hate me for it not true
that's true don't think she's ever
really processed and mom died
you do that another time
yes
do I look like I'm not calm
just to think I was the funniest person
in the world
what happens to everybody
[Music]
are you okay
I lost all my money
what is wrong with you she doesn't like
me with him actually Eric she has a
little crush on you for some demented
reasons one for the books I'd say well
how can everybody
[Music]
other night would that make you feel
better
you're doing a bit of the old Painting
the Town seeing my friends getting
business done
[Music]